laughs awesome
the flashpoint action you want this
what's going on man talk to us oh yeah
these this week at Bungie has been quiet
for a little while but after the
development update on the 11th we have
had some more things to talk about so
wanted to get just kind of a chat going
on about these things gonna get old feel
of the way the week's go and you know at
least it's something to talk about in
the Destiny world as so many of us still
want to enjoy the game would be
passionate about it but you know some
and many are not thrilled with what's
going on but I'm gonna toss it over to
you to kick us off and kind of get
things rolling so let's hear it this is
something we've been talking about for a
while obviously bonds is my man you know
we've known each other for a bit now and
you know we'd love this damn game love
it so we still trying to figure out
what's going on you know there's a lot
of updates that's up and trickling out
and stuff like that but ultimately I
mean it just comes down to the passion
for destiny wanting it to improve
wanting it to get back to its its glory
era so to speak and you know we're
probably gonna be doing this from time
to time and ever since the Guardian con
when we first met you know we the only
two guys there with business cards when
you try and grow your channel you never
quite know what options are gonna work I
did get one comment that actually said
it was from the con but probably not a
lot of things and I'm just like man I
pontus knows his destiny you know and it
was just so cool just kickin it you know
at the events and you know having a good
time and you know just just being
passionate about this community that we
still love so something that I've been
always wanting to do and I figure why
not today
right hey seems like a good day for it
we're wrapping up January which seems
crazy because we already hit 2018 but
this months almost done but ya know I
miss last dusty area Guardium con it is
now called
I went through we went to destiny con
it's to go on sale I don't know if it's
gonna be as popular this year I have a
VIP actually find of figured you know
would be a big deal if now I'm kind of
like I guess we'll see when time gets
closer but the gold the golden ticket
but yeah oh yeah we've got the updates
coming out you know we've done our sat
down with the iron Lords at the table
talked about the the big update I had my
half an hour thirty seven minute video
whatever and I had about the developer
update there's like to talk about and
there always is with destiny so I mean
we'll try at least stick with the Bungie
weekly update just to kind of cover
details but I'm sure some of these will
bring up other topics and we'll go from
there
absolutely absolutely let's dive in man
let's get into this thing so as you guys
probably know faction Early's came
through give me a quick thought what
were your thoughts on faction allies
alright faction really for me it was
kind of like from a new monarchy
perspectives absolutely loved it it's
from an ornament perspective I thought
the ornaments looked fantastic
you know they Tim me new monarchy has
the best homer by far and um yeah man I
mean the big thing though was was the
weapons and I know a lot of other people
in the community was pretty upset
because Bungie didn't explain what
actually what happened as far as that
process is concerned but people thought
they were gonna get all I guess what the
season two weapons in the from faction
rally yeah and when that didn't happen
you know there was there was a bit of
unrest so I wasn't too affected because
again my purpose was more the ornaments
and I really wanted that full set to do
all those little kind of tasks for that
but I couldn't understand for my guys I
wanted the weapons have it they could be
upset did you get the set got everything
going on Titan looks down with that lion
on his chest so that was there that was
actually for me I haven't grinded for
much and destiny to in a while and it
was actually something to grind for
there was a real like one of the ones
was to do patrols that I think could
have been the first time to actually do
patrols like they had a purpose behind
them I think that was the first time
I've seen
that for me the weapons I think the
communication unfortunately really stunk
now everybody assuming that hey you know
we're gonna have access to all these
other weapons I don't remember how it
went and season 1 if you if there were
other weapons dropping but we just
didn't get the one of the week I know
like I got a random from the caves chest
I've got random faction weapons I don't
know if they stopped that because it's
been a while since I've got one but I
think it would have been a nice balance
if okay over the course of the season
somehow we're gonna have like three or
four or five faction arrows and forget
how many they said but you have what
nine different weapon types so a couple
so the ones that aren't gonna be part of
that for season two hey these are the
ones that you can get from engrams for
each of the factions so if we run new
monarchy the first time you could get a
chance at I don't know scout rifle or
auto rifle that's not gonna be part well
the auto rifle was but whatever isn't
gonna be in their plan throw the other
ones in there so we have an option for
other stuff like yes the art team always
makes usually a full set of weapons so
you know let's have access to some but
maybe not all in you know communicate so
I was like I don't think it was the end
of the world that we didn't get them all
the communication apparently people
assumed I want all the stuff like okay
they didn't communicate it so we didn't
know but again big yeah I think just
communication would go a long way but if
there's a full set of weapons give us
some I agree I agree like I say we're
just just confusion bad messaging on
their part that they didn't you know I'm
saying like let people know but what you
know I actually don't mind it now that I
know what the process is yeah I don't
you don't mind it you know Sam so but I
mean I can understand some people you
ever send oh no it's instant
gratification for all of society so
there's a whole philosophical debate
that comes up later so new monarchy so I
guess we'll see how their communication
goes for the next one but for now I love
how the call to salad bar for iron man
iron banana I don't know
salad in I guess that's what the salad
so yeah it starts next week with the
January update which will get down to a
little bit later but control will be the
game mode which 4v4 control kind of know
how that won't go
what are your general thoughts on iron
banner so far homes kind of leave at
heart fear on the hand cannon which
looks snazzy Oh take a look nice I can't
front a but yeah let me tell you right
now watch this man it's so disappointing
for me right now it's just right now hey
brain it just feels like a crucible skin
you know and from me the big things were
that the lack of the power narrative
like that is minuscule as some people
say it is
I still feel it meant it made a
difference it gave you a reason to grind
to get your light up you know so that
that definitely was something else a
little disappointed and then I don't
know man it just you know I'm still
adjusting to force in an iron banner a
little bit as well and I know we know
sixes are coming back down the road but
um it's just a different feel it's just
a different feel I just I just miss I
guess sixes from a standpoint I like if
you catch a r18 you know you're saying
six can actually go play Ironman and
yeah you don't have to split up the
squad so to speak kind of thing so you
know right now you know as far as the
rewards and stuff you know I've seen
some ornaments stuff that looks cool you
know but um a lot of it just comes down
to you know just them addressing the
meta addressing the token system and
stuff like that so let's deep dive what
what what are they talking about now
what's going on
so for iron banner they're gonna kick it
off it's gonna be first time for season
two so they're gonna have a couple of
changes even though they seem a fairly
minor from what I can tell they're gonna
be bringing three weapons basically is
your chance to get those so they're
saying season two weapons on iron banner
we'll be adding more in the next event
here's a look at what we can expect this
week so first you've got the hand cannon
as we said you can see the rifling in
the barrel chamber like come on so
that's was like as oh and that's why I
guess sometimes when as I started my
other video take a second remember all
of the people involved in the game the
art teams of production the music
there's so many teams that make a game
that when you bash it for like ever
verse and who knows who makes those
decisions but it's like it could be
Bungie Activision CEOs money who knows
the reasons they're like there's a good
chunk of that studio absolutely killing
themselves which most unfortunately game
development studios do putting out like
a gun that looks like this
absolutely shout out to our team look at
that I mean it's really it's really nice
and they don't get enough credit and
these are the kind of things that make
you want to continue to play destiny
alright like look how fantastic the art
team does you know in the craft teams
just pretty amazing stuff you know
something you got the rail underneath
you've got the ornament up there
the wolf is mean that goal like the text
rings on the trigger like but the fact
that I got the rifling inside the barrel
I'm like oh yes come down to scout rifle
salute number two vice I think a cool
foundry I like how this is the new one
more kind of angular and usually having
triangles and kind of more points
involved which is cool I like how I
don't know if you see my little mouse
cursor on your side it's actually got
where you basically pull back the slide
to almost like feed the magazine a
little bit yeah and then just the scope
but that's a really long long barrel and
that one and then you've got the shotgun
clean simple sorrow shotgun journal
chatty yep just a little bit of
texturing all of that looks really cool
and then we come down here to some of
the cosmetics so Everest right throw
some iron banner stuff in there and
there's a nice little blip at the bottom
the only thing not pictured is the iron
banner ship we'll save that for when you
discover it yourself I don't know what
that's gonna involve but even just a
little texture in here on these like
again our team crush in it but the
cosmetics are not behind Tess Everest
says it's they've told us in the crimson
days they're gonna have a lot of things
and they're gonna be changing more and
more coming that direction so that's
good yeah I'm kind of with you iron
banner used to feel like it mattered
more and even if the power level most
people were maxed they didn't really
matter your reasons who want to be like
I just want to go in at full power so I
guess I should infuse this thing or
whatever the feeling was iron banner as
you said it's a reskin for me it's just
like instead of crucible I always
picture red from Jax now this one is
just green like today it feels like a
crucible reskin like there's no
differentiate and then you know it's the
sad part about it watch this is that in
the lore shout out to shout the
Confessor is sleepy chat in the law
is supposed to matter right absolutely
that's the crazy part we're going away
around with that but continue
oh no and yeah but I mean as you're
saying power should matter but the mode
doesn't do anything to differentiate
them so itself so you could have maybe
there's a modifier maybe there's just
anything to make it different so it
actually felt like something besides go
to a different vendor for your awards
like that it doesn't do much for me I
mean yeah there's some cool stuff in
here and I have no idea how the guns are
gonna shoot but outside of grinding for
just another gun doesn't do much for me
I agree absolutely all right so as we
kind of scroll down the page here it's
like yeah lacklustre iron banner so far
we'll see if they ever make it
systematically different wait hold on I
got interruption what say ye more cars
in the chat talking about he don't like
the new monarchy rat rod and he said it
looks like Red Riding Hood how dare you
besmirch I went I I decked out my Titan
I knew it looked good if you went if the
hunter doesn't look good I don't have a
thought on the attack he's got a problem
with the hoods going over the hunters
like to be the ears and stuff ya know
he's got a problem
that's how good is fire lorca bazi you
out of control right now you at a bow
continue we want it now you're good
they also say if you're missing items
from last season so season 1 they will
still drop as possible rewards from the
Ingram which I guess that works not sure
they said there's also a new emblem that
tracks how many lifetime ring cups so
it's actually just your overall level
now which is a way to track that as
opposed to I guess shows packages you've
opened even though I feel like you kind
of have that already don't we like did
in the previous if you got the emblem
for the milestone or something you'd
have it I can see how many packages have
opened yeah emblem I believe it was like
when you finished it yet the emblem it
does track packages I'm pretty confident
it does oh I guess they're doing that
again maybe adding a second emblem that
doesn't emblem yeah it has and again
just another color so there's more of
that come down here they said iron
banner events players prefer to acquired
the items directly so if you actually
want to purchase some of these things
you will now be able to so
you can get the three different weapons
that are available it may take shards or
iron banner tokens things like that and
also got their list of ornaments
all-trans ooh min so you guys can see
this here yeah so we've got the I've got
the helm on my Titan so I mean if it
looks different it's pretty minor but
all of these here just affection rewards
but you got the ornaments yeah and I'm
kind of curious if the ornaments are
gonna be something like the affection or
others were where you have to go do
certain things maybe in PvP yeah they
actually are because um they gave us a
preview of them even before this dropped
if you had any iron banner gear you can
actually preview it and they see some of
the requirements for it epilogue I'm so
I mean that's actually kind of a cool
thing so if you've got a piece all right
and you want to grind for you know the
curse of Osiris alternative for example
you can and maybe it's just gonna be you
know get precision kills get this it's
but it's a reason to go play crucible a
little differently they have a lot of
they have a lot of a game I know that
Spore grammatically but they have a lot
of game to use they need to give you
reasons to go play it differently find
different ways to use it
so absolutely that's actually I'm okay
so that's good and if there's a weapon
you just don't get to drop and you're
like damn I know what the hand can and
you've got some tokens go get it
now here's defending the wood box I got
a comment on a weapons though um I don't
know how I feel about that like go buy
them you know what I'm cool with the
armor because we know how like the armor
you know you could just get unlucky you
know arms whatever and you can't get
unlucky with no weapons it's just that I
don't know how I feel about this new
philosophy of them putting featured
weapons in iron banner as well as rate
it I don't know what part of me kind of
misses that aspect of orangey you know
yeah I mean and wanting to keep quite
because now if I think about this if we
play and I get enough tokens whatever
get enough chuck-e-cheese or whatever it
is yeah pick up the weapon and
essentially I'm done for iron banner I
mean unless you like really want to
grind for the armor ornaments there's
not as much because as we'll probably
get down into a rant otherwise armor
doesn't matter too much but sidebar that
for a minute lissa um yeah but yeah like
if you want to go buy weapons now let me
ask you this what
at one point during iron banner if you
collected enough tokens for your
featured weapons you can only pick what
perfect I'm good with that I'm good
I just don't like see what I'm worried
about is there so now in this defensive
mode of trying to accommodate the entire
journey that they Tron it's almost like
they're just you'll get a weapon in your
weapon and you get everything it's like
okay I get it you want to appease the
community community's upset but I don't
want it be that you get everything
because that's what gets people to stop
playing it there has to be some level of
grind to keep us coming back so say I
was like em just random ID here say your
first iron banner match you get one
specific you get a lord saladin you get
the point that looks like his giant
flaming thing behind him so like a coin
that looks like the gong you get one
after your first match so you have to
play once as you go through the week you
grinded you got that you got one of the
weapons you get to the last day before
you're about to go to sleep you're like
alright I gotta pick you and your token
can be spent on one other thing we had a
weapon say you got them all you wanted
to get one ornament but you didn't play
the right way like one token that you
could basically drop on the single item
that you say couldn't get or expecting
for mm-hmm
yeah that would be kinda cool
so I mean those are little things like
think a little bit outside the box to
where give us like if somebody wants to
grind all day yeah they're probably
gonna get most of them but just like you
know orangey odds and things like that
and I like the ornaments having kind of
bounty you feel to them but you have
something that like still have people
make choice and I think come down as we
get to Gales in the chat he's saying
question wouldn't you agree that it'd be
better if I Amana weapons themselves
were more more influence like a weapon
for scoria should be influenced visually
by her not the user scheme or like a
jolt Irgun make it chunky and Titan like
I'm cool with that you know yeah I mean
like everything seems to match a very
clean aesthetic here like there's no
distinction between them so yeah they
did a lot of that in Destiny one I guess
for the names but I would say the lore
going into some of them maybe if it was
a wrap of and maybe just do one of those
every so often but yeah I'd love to see
like a you know old or shotgunners you
said machine we don't even have machine
guns anymore or any machine guns yeah
any of those have one cool just like
iron banner but to a completely
different level like a very different
one one that you want and that'd be cool
absolutely yeah yep so we'll see
I mean armor is still armor it all just
looks different doesn't really do much
for me for the way my character feels
but the weapons we'll see I wish but
yeah as I said I wish they made them
more scarce here's your full set of
ornaments what do you thinking Shogun II
feel I'm necessary I'm I'm cool with it
I'm cool I think I think the design I
mean from a war like mama it's all about
all but now Real Talk
the Titan looks mean I love the way the
time walks what's your feeling what you
feel no I mean I like again they look
freaking awesome
like all due to their own aspect like
the Titan looks sick I wish I could
actually pause this but I can't what I
mean even the gloss and the just the
detail of front say like the Titan boots
like you do that and then just the
ornate like every little [ __ ] of armor
around the warlocks bottom of the robe
yeah and then no offense but the top of
the type the hunter may look ridiculous
but it also looks kind of badass at the
same time yeah it kind of reminds me it
had error that whole samurai and you
know an era like this whole little theme
and motif they go I'm the art team got
like look at the stuff they put out man
and this is that's why they got to make
this thing matter but I heard mass works
me addressed if we don't get into it
later
for an opinion so that's what this is
for
alright so well yeah season two
ornaments look cool so and hopefully
those are just ones you can acquire
multiple times throughout the season so
if you don't grind the first one maybe
I'll get the next one so iron banner
overall I mean I'm kind of with you
generally it feels like a reskin I mean
the skin itself looks awesome art team
puts it out but my does
to go after some of this still doesn't
feel like it's pulling me back in the
game if I'm not playing it right now if
I'm gonna go dive in to save Monster
Hunter it's like I'm really just gonna
put down a brand new game to go play a
different color PvP it doesn't feel like
it for me what great it they all look
freaking cool so and the next piece of
the update we come to masters of the
armor so as you guys know masterwork
weapons have been out there we of course
assumed masterwork armor was coming they
told us it was so similar idea is same
thing works with the course the more
difficulty activity the better chance to
get a masterwork all that we'll go
through but you still have a chance to
get him anywhere
it's always nice when they just pop out
of random Ingram's from her hole he's
he's not very generous but occasionally
he's nice of the masterwork armour so I
hoped it did so at least it does it is
going to stack so the density Liston
stacks do you think 15% total damage
reduction is enough it depends I mean
they gotta walk a fine line I mean this
this to me completely benefits roaming
supers you know and they needed a bit of
love I like I like the fact that they
each armor piece does stack so I thought
that part of it was cool um it's gonna
be see they're 14 but I gotta see how
this is in real world gameplay you know
as far as PvP versus PvE
like oh do we really feel tanky with
their 15% you know that kind of deal
that that's gonna be the key if I'm a
strong Kong I'm running around you know
how tanky am i if I have a full set of
masterwork Omron you know shout out to
the guys like you know fall out please
and those guys will break it down like
you're curious gift now does one point
less damage all that stuff but yeah like
see this is where I
it's an overall system thing they've
said it from before they won't have to
have pvp and PVE feel the same if you
walk your gun into one it's gonna feel
the same in the other buddy but again
this is also where I want to divide them
or if I had the benefits in PvE where if
I was wearing masterworks hay and or say
for example there were two different
sets of master work armor there was a
PvP maybe it did for three or more
percent then take a PvE and think that
up to like I don't know ten or twenty
percent so if you wear a full set and
you want to go jump into the middle of
mayhem you're really alive for the whole
seven eight ten seconds that you get to
use your super that you
you're meant to feel like a god and I
wish in PvE that they would let you do
that
just to a different level in judging
it's kind of a you can't walk around
with a hundred percent damage reduction
or not hundred but you know fifty
percent damage on for something like
that cuz yeah then you'll go mop the
floor with the whole team so I
understand where they like the balance
of 15 somewhere fifteen to twenty what
sound good for PvP I just wish they
would divide it and maybe you had a PvP
set and then you could work for a PvE
set that gave you better benefits for
strikes or some of those crazy PvE
situations if you want to solo it you
grind it for it you know hey I feel a
bit more awesome so I think I think also
for me the only disappointment I have my
major disappointment with massive armor
so far is I thought there would be like
another rollable stat yep like similar
how like master weapon hands so like my
you know you have the magazine you have
to whatever whatever now I get it
they're letting you reroll what is it
recovery like the type basically like
exactly which is okay you know I'm
saying but at the end of the day it's
like you know I still want a little bit
more out of it you know I'm saying like
so you're yeah if you're gonna re-roll
master org say whatever piece you get
say you can give them either another
slot or make it to where you can pick
two different perks like if you want it
to be heavy and you'll I want to re-roll
the one part that's in mobility and
throw that in a result resilience as
well make it ultra heavy let that's what
you're saying it's like give me more
control over the stats and they took
that away from what the guns did so yeah
absolutely and here's the other problem
let's be honest who's really gonna be
rolling the whole configuration aspect
is limited in a sense now who's gonna be
rolling for mobility like that when it's
just straight speed isn't it yeah it's
useless yes so it's like unless unless
they make an overall sandbox change to
mobility right no one's gonna be this is
just really configuring everything into
restorative and resistance I mean yeah
that's like everybody wants a decent run
resilience to have that you know amount
of hit points so when you take those
shots you're not gonna die in four it
takes you five or whatever and then
everyone's recovery does he get back in
the fight fight faster and that was if
you listen to my video and I'll probably
put a link up on it and if you want to
go to my channel you'll find it's the
only thirty seven minute video I have
recently don't matter none of them do
right now so hold on one second he's
lost Lee in the chat talking about he
run for more Billy do you know it's only
stream speed it's like sprint down a
hallway and you're not gonna outrun out
ready anyway they gotta make a sandbox
change mobility to make it more
attractive there's no reason to really
do it anymore like it's just they get
they got to me the sandbox update needs
to come in the first way yeah so good
spring can't get here enough oh yeah I
mean that's kind of one of those I
thought say for example and this would
be kind of a cool thing for masterworks
to add more to it say you only had ten
stat points total straight-up total but
say you had you know a group of three or
four hundreds the wind
everybody stacked mobility to the max
but say they sprinted like a crazy
person like they ran like they were you
know running away from some bad but on
the other end say you have four Titans
that are running resilience now if
you're running a control match for
example okay yeah those hunters can run
back and forth all day long and cover
what they need to but say you have two
Titans that split up and go and duo's
and basically say they have 300 health
versus you know basically a team that
has four and you almost have an even
match but in very very different stats I
can tether and outrun you all day but if
I run into your heart is held to kill
that's what I want for armor I want it
to matter like I want this ads and that
recover I still can't figure out where
that throws in the mix between speed and
health but maybe like recovery is almost
more like
I don't know but I want those type of
decisions like I want if I go full
mobility I really want to flat out run
that other person by a good you know
minute by the time I'm done running
something like make it make a difference
so absolutely I completely agree yeah so
I'd love to see stats me more so as I
agree with you the I'm glad I'm so glad
at Stax if it didn't stack this was
gonna be like a waste so the stack is at
least a step in the right direction I'd
like to see maybe a little more but as
you also said it only affects roaming
supers basically everything that's Ark
be it striker storm caller and Ark
Strider if I'm saying that correctly yep
but like say celestial Nighthawk Golden
Gun on a boss they get zero benefit from
an entire stack it just doesn't do them
any good there's no gain a Golden Gun in
PvE still most of the time you're not
really trying to survive unless you're
trying to like finish off a nightfall
boss and you're the last one but more
often than not you're not gonna get
benefits Nova bomb no matter what you do
as soon as you fire it it's done where
is their benefit from a yes yes it does
it if you're an on roaming super you
don't get any benefit let you it becomes
a a PvE only they'd even then you still
don't really get you're gonna be from a
distance shooting yeah you're right
yeah lives and hammers they get a
benefit but Golden Gun doesn't so it's
like for like five you and for don't but
again if I like running the ones that
roam are the ones that don't if I want
to run you know Golden Gun I've you very
little benefit to this and I think
that's kind of that kind of sucks so
that's where I think the stats could
have done more at least to give them an
extra benefit so that's my general
thoughts on it roll down the page so you
can rework the steps on armor as we said
basically it's the stat package as
you've seen so you have a heavy a light
no mobility recovery whatever the ones
are for your class you're just gonna be
able to roll between those now it's only
one master record which isn't as bad not
quite as many cores because you might
want to do that a couple of times yeah
so they have one little bug they didn't
say it doesn't take your yes it does
which is good it doesn't take your
materials away but it can be scary if
you like I spend it and nothing happens
so it's saying if you
rework the mess worker more too quickly
in a row apparently it's just gonna like
not do anything so it doesn't sound game
breaking or any mean but at least they
know it and this is one of those things
honestly where I appreciate it
they're like hey we know this bug is
here nuts nothing's gonna happen just
watch out it can't happen like what
happened what I like is the transparency
with it because that's been here issue
like you know how is it that the
community is finding out you know I'm
saying these issues before they do sort
of the fact that they tested it and then
also what transparent the these are
signs in the right direction this is the
kind of stuff you want to see from bunch
the line is way out there but at least
they're stepping in the right direction
all right so yeah I mean masterworks
again yeah armor is kind of it steps in
the right direction but you know some
supers will really enjoy this I mean
strike your Titans which already are
kind of ridiculous just got a little
stronger so yeah yeah so have fun in the
crucible all of you are people enjoy the
benefits those are things like running
the supers
I'm sorry you get to look pretty that's
I mean in all fairness in PvP they got
it needed a bump you know I mean the
wrong supers yeah it's like unless
you're just gonna like wait around the
corner for somebody to pop up and then
slam it's harder to cover that ground I
mean it's cool that they roam how they
change them from destiny one but yeah
it's hard to take advantage of them
without getting just you know especially
I feel like arc Strider got the worst
luck right or what just get wailed on
pretty constantly because they don't
have the blink and then cover quite as
much ground so you doubt that I will say
this though shout-out to when mayhem
dropped I was in that mayhem a lot I'll
bring that back oh yeah which I don't
know where why they got rid of it but um
yo there's just some little evasive move
that they got it's like this flip and I
was shooting over moms and I could not
kill this damn mark strike close the
distance so fast so there's some little
I don't know what sub-tree that that is
that they do that that little flip and
it's kind of like closes the distance
and it's very evasive
yeah I think I know what you're talking
about I just yeah I don't actually think
in the meta that people are doing all
the time so alright so now we come to
the raid and the changes they're making
to their rewards by the way if you want
to talk to
to say raid reward rework quickly it's
not gonna go well
Oh basically they said the in-game
experiences feel lackluster to say the
least it's kind of a way to sum it up
but they want to change the way you get
their awards so the first ones is raid
perks which thank you thank you so much
why were these gone I don't know but I'm
so glad they're back so these are big
now you look at the perks and I'm
already looking down below just from the
cloak alone yep light me up this is
looking good mm-hmm so let's I'll cover
the details here in a second but so
you've got mods that are gonna peer from
new drops from the raid armor they're
reusable so if you select one you can
just you know pick the one you need it
may take you a shard or a Calais token
or something if you want to switch it
but generally it's not gonna be too hard
to you know use these when you want to
which is really nice that they're not
like hey okay it's gone which is good so
we don't hope til they have to manage
anymore in our inventory and then we
come down here so what they wanted to do
with these is make them not specific to
the raid as much for encounters but
overall use for your character so right
example here that's on screen and it's
the hunter cloak so looks like you've
got the option for all three damage
types the one selected is your solar
abilities do 25% more damage that's
large that's a big that's a big jump
you're right that's one way to finish
I'm gonna bite my tongue but yeah that's
that's big I'm not gonna minimize that
so I mean think about when you have a
modifier of and this is where I want
more modifiers than all other parts of
the game like solar burn and stuff that
used to do but think about like a
celestial Nighthawk on Calais now 25%
extra damage he's just gonna drop faster
so I mean I like the fact that they're
giving you nice benefits to grind for so
I mean I like the fact that these are
here but they want broadly useful perks
like recharger grenade when you activate
your super which I'm not entirely sure
about that one being that beneficial
unless it's just instantly [ __ ]
which mean I've got it be a fast
recharge for that to be effective
yeah deal 20% extra damage after giving
a melee kill I guess we're gonna be
stabbing a lot more stuff
seems hit or miss so I guess it just
kind of depends on how some of these
feel and how useful they're gonna be it
seems like the class that I might have
the best one so I kind of gave a little
bit before going to the next section now
you're chomping at the bit over there
okay this is a big subject for me
because you know I know a lot of shot up
- a lot of acting stuff like a lot of my
raid team is kind of going by the
wayside and a lot of it had to do with
this frame Awards what are we getting
what are they gonna do to address it and
you know we're from that era of you know
you play Oryx you get a speed buff when
doing such such a such activity or you
know you're playing rat to the Machine
you pick up the what is it the shot
cannon you get a speed boost one you
know I mean like there would be very
specific mechanics in the encounter that
would help you and I kind of missed that
I'm not gonna lie now I understand what
they're saying that as far as the dev
team and he's like look they wanted to
go away from specific stuff and kind of
do broad stuff but I don't understand
why we can't do both absolutely agree
like I mean if you're holding an orb for
example or you're the one and say if you
go in the Shadow Realm
maybe you just or maybe not in the
shower um it's not as much safe you're
the one in the throne room you know if
in winning callouses room you take 10%
let you you know take less damage or
some just a general thing that to make
that if you grind it enough to get a
full set maybe if you're gonna go run
people through a little bit more
successful I mean it you've already put
the work in exactly at minimum on the
prestige level right because my thing is
I'm hoping for something like okay we
all jump on catalyst plates you get 10%
or 15% increase to reload speed on
palace plates you know I'm saying like
something specific I don't understand
why there's why they want to go away
from that so bad I don't understand why
why was that necessarily a bad thing you
know don't get me wrong we charge you
agreed an activating the super 20%
actually they're like these are very
based on statistics they have
we're all powerful numbers it definitely
sounds like it
well at least game pack - I mean
impacting you know I'm saying but I just
don't understand why they felt the need
to still go away what was so wrong about
destiny one system of giving specific
encounter perks like what what's the
issue with that so I'm still a little
confused no I mean I'm with you it's
like for I mean Calais you can do it
multiple ways where their benefit people
in the Shadow Realm but if it people in
the throne room the plates as you said
it's perfect that's when you're doing
damage I mean those things would be nice
they had like taken had an overall
taking King had an overall theme like
you know what was it less damage when
you're in the Shadow Realm or something
like that
yeah yeah so I mean that was one when
you're running when you're the run of
the orb and you've got half the you know
map shooting at you occasionally you
might survive a little better if you
have to be the one and I guess that may
be part of the way the encounters are
built there's not the one clutch person
either holding card a sword or running
the platforms and taking king or the
three people say shooting in siva
basically yeah so there's not those
specific pieces where someone has to do
something it's basically you know you
have your mechanics to the fight and
there's no one clutch person who's gonna
go smack the boss so I guess I mean
there's it's harder to have I guess more
of a specific thing to that front but
know it's some benefit as you said
callus plates that's the hardest fight
when I go into prestige I want the
previous normal raid well which some of
these will do but I think specific
fights especially the callous fight
would be nice I got I got a theory on
why they may be doing that is because
they go with this whole raid layer thing
yeah and I think because it's a raid
layer and it's we have another one
coming right because if you know is look
at the perks the perks a Leviathan so I
think that maybe the reasoning why I'm
just trying to get myself into mindset
as to why they're doing it but you know
what hope for like prestige like what's
gonna separate prestige stuff and is it
gonna have anything different the drops
or is it more of the same exactly like
so what what what's the difference so
that that's my thing like being now and
prestige had 35% mm-hmm just not what
we're looking at right here prestige
they did be like okay
that much better or that's Lee saying in
the chat is that remember how we've
always wanted a reason to wear the full
set
why can't maybe proceed yeah like when
you have the full set on you get XY and
Z it I'm totally with shout out to sleep
I mean zero in a chat right now he's on
fire but yeah like I'm completely with
that like they have that we've always
wanted that since d1 because let's be
honest we always put on an exotic we'll
always do something to break up the set
so make the set more hold more value you
know like did you play Diablo yes so
yeah Diablos that bone is the same thing
and there can be more that's but on the
other end hey what about a crucible set
bonus if I'm gonna go where a legendary
crucible set bonus maybe there's
actually a reason to go turn in all my
packages and work on doing something
like that because maybe in crucible
you're one person faster but if I have
the whole set a 1% crucible I'm still
faster than you so Leah for the right
I'd love to oh man I was a 2-page like
if you were three and then you were the
full five like yes however some type of
set bonus that'd be great and shut up
gotta check he's saying at home division
gear kind of style they do that ya know
yeah I mean nails that front it is no
reason why best he can be I completely
agree has to be all right I told you
we'd have some tangents guys long point
so so double drops so for clearing
prestige now gives you prestige and
normal drops which just makes sense now
as I said and I think you kind of agree
it'd be nice if prestige was something
different not just another color so if
you're gonna go beat your head against
the prestige wall which is already hard
enough if you actually go accomplish it
it'd be nice to get a little extra from
it so that'd be kind of cool raid
encounters always drop a raid piece
again a destiny quest destiny one thing
that was not brought to destiny to that
when you finish an encounter you get
something besides I got my I got my
tickets I'll go turn them in later
same thing so and I also said every
encounter has a chance to drop an exotic
that is decrypted so you can start using
it now that saves you know for a
different discussion about exotics not
really matter that much right now as we
run without one and still be fine so
they were gonna revisit that the last
night develop so hopefully collect all
the ones you can now and then maybe the
decisions might we mean more later but
hey at least if they're putting them in
there is an option it'd be nice but
honestly if it was like hey you have an
exotic at this but hey at the end of
callous you have like a 10% chance for
an exotic question drop you know so go
get that stuff back in there too don't
forget about the crazy quest that we all
wanted to grind for so again baby steps
and I know they can't fix everything and
this is what three weeks basically from
the update so it's not bad for a few
weeks and we'll see more as it comes
through here we go to the raid vendor
sells a rotating selection of gear but
now this is kind of an interesting one
they said for prestige so for okay for a
cost of legendary shards and callous
tokens you can purchase these pieces if
you completed that raid for the week for
instance if you wanted to buy the
prestige chest armor you need to
complete the prestige mode before you
can do so okay so I like that you can't
just go buy prestige
if you are wearing that you legit still
have to earn it which is kind of close
which is good yeah and again I think
would probably give more benefit to
those pieces but I also kind of wonder
is if he sells the piece and you're like
hey the only one that really means
anything if like if all the perks don't
matter and save the class items still
the best one
if I just go to the raid once I don't
get it I go buy it and I feel like I'm
kind of done
yeah I'm still kind with you on like I
don't know if they should be selling
right here yeah I don't know how I feel
about or at least there should be a
limit you know maybe I don't know I'm
probably I just it's a it's a weird line
for me this is that Hawthorne II kind of
stuff that I don't like which is like
you know you get raid armor and you get
ready but like it has to be a prestige
activity it has to be something you know
this is what separates the casuals and
and the people who are really dedicated
to the game it the people who
grind need to be rewarded and something
to show off for that level of dedication
if someone doesn't have the time I get
it you know you maybe have the ability
to get one week I still don't know how
to completely attack it and balance it
but I don't know how I feel about just
going up to you know oh boy
sweeping and just you know hey let me
get this chest I'm still struggling
mm-hmm
shout out to the saltiest he's calling
participation trophies and that that
brings back to a whole point of just
kind of gaming in general right now and
the way a lot of people complain about a
lot of things in dusty one I don't have
the trials gear because honestly for one
it's beyond salty on PC which is crazy
if I looked at the numbers on destiny or
edit but to me and me and the people
that I've played with I am not upgraded
at PvP and people just can mop the floor
with me but you know what if I haven't
earned the trials gear I haven't earned
it and I think people always seem to
want it a way to get everything and
they're okay limiting that stuff in
crucible but they feel weird about let
me to get in PvE
I don't know I don't know why they make
him they feel okay limiting crucible in
which I'm getting beat up by a person
but again it's like if there's content
that's difficult and say you can't do it
then the same principle thank you hey
shout out the command chair he's saying
my casuals and collectors are fine which
strikes at night falls he said but let
raised and trials be for the Hong Kong
idea like I remember the days in Deewani
pontus when you stepped in that tower
and you seen another Guardian with a
full race enter a full trial set and
you're like yo how did you get that it
made you want to play that hardcore
activity it made me want to raise so
it's just like I gotta agree like they
did what it is is there in this Mia
culpa state because they know they
messed up and they got to fix teach it
and make things to be won but I just
don't want them to go so overboard that
knowledge is giving stuff away they
still has to be levels to it there has
to be I mean there has to be a challenge
too
we still want to grind for something
just like the black spindle quest same
principle it's like we all knew it was
out there and it felt awesome to finish
it but that was the cool part about it
it felt like an accomplishment now and
this feels like you're just kind of
pushing it's all what feels like
data-entry versus like you know an
athlete that's nothing it's like you can
do your date you can do your basics and
do this and you can kind of get your
gear and get up to 335 don't even get me
started on 335 you can get by running
public events that's yeah I was like my
buddy had run the raid more than me and
he was full raid set and I was just like
I hadn't run it as much but I was still
playing other stuff just cuz I was a
little busier no still the same level as
him and he'd run the hardest stuff in
the game and I just been grinding other
things and I still got there I'm the
milestones are fine but say the
milestones only got me to 320 the raid
was the only thing the Raider trials
were the things that got you up there
PvE and PvP eruptions in d1 and they uh
like casual eyes the game in many ways
absolutely if I can rein us back in here
to the next I'm sure paths again
flashpoint the quickest points yeah
usually nothing but that's like exotic
raid ghosts now this is kind of cool
so the nano Phoenix that ships it I
definitely never gone I saw Mesa Sean
got it out there so you grind it a lot
you might get it but not even the people
who Grendel I never do so one of the
cool things that now you can get is at
the end the final encounter for either
the raid or eater of worlds you can get
the contender shell which makes sense
because it's cool make sure he looks
kind of kind of sick so you got the
callous logo on top and bottom for the
Leviathan ship and it's got a couple
perks too so first off it says the
seeker of brilliance enables the chance
for encounters to draw up bright engrams
from there
so just by running the raid you have a
chance of just extra bright engrams
and it's something yeah I think they're
just from the update from crimson day
from crimson crimson days whatever's
come and you can get the crimson and
grams from milestones you can get them
from just playing matches there their
understanding be like okay we're just
gonna start throwing these engrams that
you saw you showed up like and they're
gonna give you as many chances as
so I'm fine with that so and every time
one doesn't drop a bride and groom you
increase the chance for the next so
probably someone the read you're gonna
get one Braden grim arrayed and if you
don't get that much experience in there
well this is way for them to make up for
it while they're trying to fix the whole
experience bug which eight it's
something so I'll take it then they also
said the exotics that can drop from
encounters well seeker of opulence means
the exotics have a 50% chance to pull
from a list of exotics you haven't
collected so basically this I almost say
acting like a faded Engram in the sense
like yeah half a faded in gram per se
but yeah so it's you and if you get one
there's half a chance it's not going to
be now this the balance of okay it's
cool if the exotics are there but I also
feel like exotics aren't that hard to
get in the first place yeah which you
turn in milestones I feel like every
other one has it like whatever I getting
in an exotic half the time I feel like
they're so again this goes back to my
point I've talked with lock eyes like
you know some of this I think sometimes
they're getting this this this mentality
to just overwhelm us with gifts you know
that may not necessarily be the answer
to resolve the issue because now we have
this EQ our plants we've got faded
engrams through your coins you know to
be honest you know without idiot had
stuff things like you said he wants its
exotics a drop in man now on a
completely different tune I keep getting
the same damn ones in the crap out of a
on PC my warlock has five of the same
chest armor in my character's inventory
and then my hunter I was wearing boots
like the Jester boots I went over I had
an Engram to decrypt and then I walked
over to Zavala turn in my milestone I
got the same boots I was literally
wearing had them equipped and then I
walked over to Rahul and he gave me the
same damn thing so I got literally with
it I went from one to three of the exact
same exotic back to back in about three
minutes and I was like that sucks
only and that takes away the feeling of
them being exotic as well like I don't I
don't know how they did the math and d1
but I don't think I got duplicates like
I did
yes it's a turd I agree and I don't know
if it's definitely the algorithm and I
don't know if it's also the pool is it
feels like there's less exact I don't
know man it's definitely something is
messed up with that or that algorithm
assistant I don't think it's also the
fact that typically you only get exotic
Armour for your class yeah there's no
like you know if somebody only plays one
class and be like little crap I've got
like six exotics for a hunter and it
having started one yet mm-hmm like those
don't even drop anymore so even if I'm
playing my Titan only I'm not gonna help
my other characters exotics so I mean
that takes away as well but I mean the
contender shell sounds cool you'll have
to do the raid you know multiple times
probably to get it from the final
encounter seems the throw stuff at you
and the final one a secret Lord which is
just a tracker for the number of times
you debated the love I FM self overall
nice I mean something like this should
have been in here from the start as
absolutely oh really difficult but again
steps in the right direction
so baby steps in the right direction
yeah but again looks cool nice and shiny
so yes sir patch notes that are coming
so armor master works are coming
unchanged of the raids
they've got Prometheus Lin's increase
base damage they yeah that's kind of
useless new characters created are not
receiving the flashpoint milestone just
bugs players and social spaces spaces oh
this is actually cool and I don't know
why it took them this long players and
social spaces like the tower receive a
notification when they're lost and found
that postmaster is full thank you yes
please
you don't know sometimes people like I
was just running around patrols for a
while little did I realize I picked up
like 40 blue engrams and my craps full
like oh oh that's what it likes that is
nice so quality life heroic strike
completions now have a greater chance of
grinning exotic rewards okay yes but
again they're throwing exotic side you
gotta find something else to give me
besides it's not how about what's up
with the disc oaring that they're gonna
be adding on knife falls what's up with
that on her own strikes that was a d1
mainstay right that's where they yeah
didn't it wasn't it only in heroics the
scoring wasn't even in night falls no I
can't remember now wait tonight I
thought well yeah I thought it was
exclusive two strikes strikes right yeah
it was never on the knife flapping with
someone else's because I mean I guess
when I soloed of no I think they were
still like a gold score yeah there
probably was cuz he had to do over the
quest so yeah yeah you may be right
there yeah right but yeah why why when
you can introduce heroic adventures that
have new modifiers you put heroic
strikes in within the same expansion and
they have zero modifiers but the same
strikes you're running and nightfalls
already have to maybe just throw one of
them on there just I agree I was like
they could be random they could be
weekly either way it could be something
to give them a difference sometimes with
attrition but it's something so sorry
that's just the whole rant right there
and just what I was trying to stop
talking this fast is this what happens
in the flash fight fixed an issue
mercury challenges are now available
during adventures that seems like
something that should have been but okay
fix an issue where curse of Osiris
strikes we're not properly granting
clean Ingram's win featured as the
knight volatility I noticed that one
because yeah yeah one quick sidebar
nothing's quick in this I'm just gonna
stop saying that know long point curse
of Osiris strikes is that not the giant
biggest slap in the face you feel like
things are rushed when they're literally
just strikes from ya campaign or
literally missions from the campaign
that are actually shorter cuz the story
bits not at the end exactly just emitted
that story part at the end you're done
with the bus you don't jump up or you
don't go through the end that's it
that's it's like that's the only
difference
it's pretty bad firstly fewer challenges
we're not appearing within quickly okay
and increase the dismantle time for
master of course I don't know who's
dismantling master what cores but I
guess my entire vault is full of works I
guess I'm done they'll delete these I
don't see that happening a lot but maybe
it was just accidental so it's
harder - it's probably deleting an
exotic now - shaders so before we open
this mini can of worms I want to give me
a quick thought on your thought on
shaders listen you know I'm a text I'm
trying to show sympathy because I'm not
gonna sit here and act like I know the
intricacies of the you know the whole
system as far as why some break down
into glimmer and some breaking the great
you know bright dust or whatever it's
called you know I'm not gonna insult
them in that manner but you know it's
one of those things that first of all
because a shader is a consumable now
this isn't a new problem that d2 has
presented itself with so you know III I
respected transparency but we need a fix
I mean the vault is we don't have enough
wall space as it is you know and what
takes up front down me a lot of your
vaults is these damn shaders you know so
they've got to get on that as quickly as
they possibly can because this is really
becoming an issue yeah so I mean they
wanted and they're pulling away from
ever verse so the fact that they
mentioned things like you know they want
them to be freely usable not limited by
availability reintroducing collections
like those are all steps in the right
direction but that's the excuse me that
stuff was working in d1 yeah so the
shader mechanics now I said they want to
reintegrator reintegrate what you could
do and st1 without losing the ability to
shade ghosts sparrows ships and all the
other stuff and I'm okay with that but
you already have the systems mostly
therefore the shading just add like add
to it and again I'm not with you I'm a
developer I don't know what it's like to
add a kiosk in and maybe they're trying
to throw the kiosk so they're trying to
find another way to make it work
that's a good point though how about the
kiosk because even if you can't again
let me not go into my programming spiel
but you I'm very surprised that kiosks
were not there from day one yeah because
I mean that was a shout-out to Destin
Allah Gary and his space
I don't know how we started this game
with a vault space issue they're like
they're gonna keep and they wanted to
keep feeding us cosmetics you got to
give us a place to put it like I this is
where the whole Jason Schreyer article
and this may be the this is the last
main point besides the fact that the
comic is coming out next week which I'm
excited for because that was good
absolutely yeah
so I wanted to it's like I would love to
know the accuracy of Cher's article to
be like it was this game was developed
in 16 months if that was actually true
there's a lot that would make sense
absolutely I mean things feel rushed
systems weren't there even curse of
Osiris felt like I mean when you have
strikes that aren't separate something
had like something I had to have a
crucible that you can't select specific
moles that's a problem yeah and they
don't have playlists and playlists when
the game started when your player burst
base was huge you wouldn't have to worry
about player pools because some people
would be picking different stuff like
some people have certain game modes and
some people don't
you'd have those but now's literally
like two ways to play Chris when you're
going did you that's that the like the
last option be like okay give them two
buttons and that's it like you have to
wonder it's like what is the quickest
thing we can get out because we only
have one month to give them crucible
options we can't do all these playlists
because that takes too much coding and
you know networking and matchmaking and
all that stuff just given to that's it
and then they had to run with it so the
fact that shaders and then as you were
saying some breakdown and the fact that
donning had two different shaders that
were the same thing but they took up two
different spots Oh like how does and
this is where again I don't know how
many times I apologize I'll save it it's
like no I don't work there I understand
that right but I want to know who sits
there and tests their games like do they
have I've heard they have a pretty large
chunk of testers I don't know how many
rands it does something along the lines
of a public test server for destiny to
make sense for spoilers that's rough
because if you get into raids and things
and spoilers and people are gonna like
data-mine the PC patches anyway so I
mean it's kind of like you're in a
losing battle as it is
but whatever testing group they have
doesn't seem to be big enough or given
enough time to get to the point of so my
inventory is full of shaders like that's
something that shouldn't be saying like
my inventory is full of artworks fine
delete some of it okay all doesn't
matter anyway but if the fact that it's
like shaders and this stuff yeah let me
go off on a side tangent if you've got
you got the creative juices flowing
right now and shut up the car but also
he's also saying some stuff in the chat
what it to me said it screams that okay
why are we repeating the same mistakes
right from from the past and to me I get
disheartened when I hear stuff like
there's already they're already working
on d3 right you know day to me cannot
there are not in any position to be
doing that right now my but you this
game launched with a lot of flaws right
to me all hands on deck should be to
resolve the d2 issues and I think all
this now kind of spills back from going
from d1 to d2 because when you went from
d1 remember if we remember rise if I'm
from I'm at mistake remember that wasn't
some D to exposed to come out during
that timeframe if I recall heard yeah
Danny got pushed back so then to me that
means they're already kind of behind the
eight-ball - it's like this there's one
part of Bungie and Activision or
whatever that's doing this creative
forecasting our head of what they want
to do and I understand that's how game
work you know you have to you do have to
do some type of you know years ahead
plan I get it but when the problems are
in the state that they are for d2 there
has to be a recommitment to the current
franchise because guess what if you've
already kind of they've already kind of
screwed up and you now the feint if you
know player base people are doing you
know destiny to streamers right now are
making apology videos about why they're
not doing content no absolutely there's
too many of them being like I can only
do this I've got to go to other things
it's like I really want to do this but I
also get tired of and some people want
it like if you want to take the high
road and be like I don't want to make
videos where I just bash Bungie and then
you have other ones that are like okay
I'm gonna bash Bungie but I don't want
to do it over
or just like I'm kind of done playing
this because I'm a streamer I've played
the living crap out of it already and
there's nothing for me to do plate
exactly all those different reasons
you've got things that are wrong things
that don't feel right in a game that
isn't as fun to watch as it used to be
yeah I mean I'm with you it's like put
destiny three on a bet and that's why I
was like yeah honestly take this
expansion and delay it yesin it exactly
this expansion to September yep and give
the people more for their money's worth
in this one right and like and then okay
just start pushing stuff back because
honestly if you take destiny to players
though most of them probably about the
season pass anyway if they didn't they
didn't so be hit but the ones who did
and you give him an expansion it'd be
like my brother told me about The
Witcher 3 one win for that game he said
it was like a 30-hour expansion for free
ooh I'm just going ok so you've already
paid for this let's make this one that
note the decent amount of our player
base probably paid for and we got the
money for let's do this to try and win
some of them back and show them we can
put something forward like if they
release an expansion in spring which
could again be March to June you never
know I don't care if it's June 20th we
neither typically still within spring
yeah if it's June 20th and that thing
actually has strikes that are different
from missions please you've got an
infinite force that you can actually go
back into as opposed to be limited to
just three adventures a week I mean all
of those like mercury is tiny in the
Gulf it works let's keep it Mercury's a
joke it's a circle it's a circle with to
it what is that oh this guy with two
little patrol beacons you know you know
and it's it's it's badly under populated
you know it's just sad to see what's
happened so it's like one of those
things like you say like this is such a
critical juncture for them all hands I
don't want to hear about d3 just like
and that's you kind of wonder above it's
like okay but she's a guy right
Activision will do it your way
and
no clue if this is true but like
Activision will try it your way we're
gonna put more things behind ever verse
we're gonna do whatever it is
okay the community's pissed can we do it
our way now and I think the fact that
you know Christopher Barrett on Twitter
is more Frank than most developers are
absolute transparency have to happen if
he's leading that charge and he's
leading the live team and we've got him
at least at the rains there's there's
hope but there's so much and that's the
other piece too if this isn't your game
right now it may not be your game for a
little while and that's kind of a hard
pill for these people to swallow but
access a division like is it
I mean people may be fading off because
it's still division but they still have
made the effort to continue for two
years on that game yeah make that game
and it's still just Division one and
it's like no no no I agree look what
they've done with rainbow succeed oh my
god yes look how they turn these games
around and it is no talk of division to
as much right they they like wanted to
give me management that we know it's
coming but like you said there's really
no push of it like hardcore just yet and
they've they're taking everything that
their community wants that they've
complained about adding it in fixed it
and then you can start you know get into
the super but I digress we're going with
that's the thing to where it's like
there's a balance between massive which
makes division and then Bungie who makes
destiny in the speed that they do things
and it was especially apparent in the
opening of division they listen to the
elite players too much and screwed over
the masses yes so that was a part that
turned so many people off of that game
where it's like you can bring some
people back but you may not resolve it
Bungie is afraid of doing some changes
but they're too afraid and or don't make
enough like say you do a sand bar as you
said the sandbox you cannot literally
wait to get your teeth into that throw
like if you have some questions feel
like hey we're doing a sandbox update
this week if you just throw some stuff
out there and there was a different gun
in the metal like every week for a
little while we were squeaking more and
more and more and more let let the your
millions of people or hundreds of
thousands depending on who are left
playing but still a bigger audience then
you have work out your kinks take your
data that way and be like hey or
gonna be messing with the sandbox a lot
it's could be a different game every
week it'll give some people reasons just
to come back have little mini patch
notes be like hey we're gonna bump our
rifles up a little bit this week see
what happens you just nailed it think
about this if doing all these problems
if the sandbox team was messing with the
meta and like you said give him bumps
and these were promises that were made
to us with destiny to that you know
because of the tools that they'll have
they'd be able to jump in you know more
quickly we'd be able to do you know
balance changes more fast where is it
cuz PvP is dying and I'm a hardcore
Peavy I'm say I'm a fairly seminar
hardcore PvP guy and that PvP and
destiny one meant so much I remember
just logging in doing my daily crucible
do remember the true meaning of war
bounty ebon says that was my jam right
there like I would do and I was sit
there and it would force me to play
different mould shacks had an old quest
line for me I can get exotic type reward
I could literally play crucible for the
entire week in the weekend with trials
and still be making progression on my
character in doing high-end activities
where is that I mean the the true
meaning of war bounty is probably one of
the prime examples of milestones versus
bounties mm-hmm and milestones are like
okay so literally just is based off the
number of kills pretty much all I think
it's based off because it's always like
a shade under of what I feel like 25%
would be for a match or whatever mm-hmm
but then it's like the bounties made you
work on something different like it was
okay
it kills with sniper rifles get kills
what if the weekly bounties are like so
the weekly bounties are sniper rifles
shotguns and sidearms and like make
people give people a reason to play
differently even if it is just for a
little while if they don't have to be
exorbitant lee long but again if it's
like get 15 kills with a side ain't
nobody know people had some reason to
use the crappy guns but yeah aspect of
the bounty system that I miss it
definitely kind of cores
due to specific activities yep so
absolutely hold on give me a two second
pause struggle for him yeah I did a chat
- yeah go hard
yes shows video so I just wanted no
clear it was a process oh yeah yeah I
mean those are just the things you miss
just your strike scoring bounties and if
they bring that back and they don't have
bounties it's like so if I see numbers
but there's no point behind them then
again why is it gonna be a milestone of
hey just get you know a hundred thousand
points and strike scoring okay it's
probably just gonna be like is it just
the same as running three strikes that
you're inevitably gonna do it
mm-hmm I was like the bounties but as I
mean the-they
pvp doesn't have the way to get there
nightfall level gear like they used to
if all you want to do is do crucible and
you're like I can't find a group for
night falls and guided games I wait
there for half an hour and then I sneeze
so I missed my acceptance like I did
that I like to go to the been waiting
for like 25 minutes I gotta go to the
bathroom it's like you I was like son of
up like that so I was like if you if say
crucibles you're thinking you want a way
to go get night fault he rewards like
okay that's fine as opposed to just kill
you stuff give me another one
those things yeah the comic book is
coming back looks cool speakers like
hell no my corns like oh crap like I
don't give a crap you know they kicking
my man out that'll be cool I definitely
can't wait for that one absolutely
couple updates of course literally when
I have my Tuesday off they screw over my
play time because every time now it's
like okay so if you're doing stuff for
you want to be ready on Tuesday yeah
well it goes down what at 10:00 a.m. my
time which is an hour before and then
it's up at 2:00 p.m. so I'm like well
what am I gonna go work out for four
hours
yeah I'm adjusting to that new resets
out it's like 3:00 a.m. which is nice
but when my work schedule goes back to
probably more normal be little different
timings for videos but just certain
maintenance is coming and I didn't even
watch the video
so absolutely I was like all in all
that's like hey Cosmo at the helm all
the guys are back they are trying in
basically the best way I can sum it up
things are not gonna happen overnight
they have a plan now what I'm really
really curious about next week we will
send out a graphical roadmap that will
illustrate the updates and have we have
planned for the coming weeks and months
along with what you can expect to find
in them nice so if you want to have if
you think this one's gonna be a long
chat yeah if you thought this was we're
gonna lose our mind next listen but this
is ultimately what we want transparency
communication the least and getting on
that path so we got that down you know
we're gonna see what will we got this
this graphical road bag I'm very
interested with that you know we need to
see more stuff like that and just like
you know and then also what I like is
the thought I'm explaining the thought
process behind decisions you know did
this week was good in the sense of okay
this is why shaders we're having this
issue so to speak into that lengthy
spiel about it I'm okay with that you
know I'm saying what I would like them
to say is okay why can't we have
balanced updates what you want to hear
like I mean you've got a full page on my
screen of shader sit down like okay
here's why they can't dismantle boards
okay here's the things like even if it
was just a balance update be like hey
this is the stuff we're seeing and then
you can have some people come and be
like okay this doesn't feel this way
this does and maybe they do or don't but
it's like you've got it now's when you
need to talk to your community and have
a balanced update before that balance
update comes out and this is what you
guys think that it's gonna be working
out auto rifles by point zero zero one
percent we swear it's gonna make a
difference
one of the worst updates for d1 when
you're like art is this really what you
guys did it never liked it didn't feel
different at all and so before they do
something like that I mean okay so I
mean we can maybe save this for letter
but for you for a sandbox update what
are you dying for besides I'm gonna say
grenade launchers just need a giant kick
in the back I just I just want them to
address different our weapon types I
just
want them to to really deep dive or
what's you know effective what's not
effective you know right now this is my
main issue right now with the matter
like um right now like heavy hating
right I'm using nameless midnight for
pretty much everything right like that
archetype of a scout we don't know yeah
I want to be able to use heavy hitting
pulses I want to be able to use you know
slow you know what's got me heavy impact
high I mean hand cannons you know
there's different archetypes that are
still really useless so I want them to
get to that and then I want them to
actually get into I know they did say
they're gonna be exotic reworks so I
know that's coming but they really
because right now master works are so
good that I'm almost running full master
work sense weapons because if you run
better Devils which just drops orbs like
a crazy person
God does it over and then something like
an auto rifle so positive outlook
Uriel's give the number whatever you
feel but you notice we don't have a long
list of options I know there's always
gonna be a meta it's kind of hard but if
cinch if they're more frequently it
would change more often that's exactly
what I'm talking about
but yeah exotics as we said in you know
the iron Lords podcast that was probably
the one part of that update when I just
wanted to put my face and might like
facepalm harder than I have in a while
it's like we want exotics to basically
feel exotic I'm like I'm gonna save the
language but it's like no kidding
kept it mostly clean so I will but it's
like how is that not a fad like exotics
don't there's a couple like merciless is
kind of the only weapon most people will
consider using over sins of the past or
curtain call
there's not really a primary that's
worthwhile and there's a couple pieces
of armor that are good but yeah why
exact they're just so afraid of making
things overpowered you know if you make
more sandbox updates some things
overpowered well you can fix it and go
make something else oh I mean like have
some fun stop trying to take d2 meta so
series like it's this like this you know
events east bar
competitive PvP you know like it's it's
destiny we're guardians were supposed to
feel powerful it's supposed to be fun
do you know how much fun and ridiculous
mayhem was when it was during dawning
just leave that in there you should just
turn that on right now and leave it
there exactly why is it going away
what like these are the things that and
the fact that when it comes back it's
limited time I was like that I was just
like um put it back now just leave it
there you know some people just want to
burn off steam and you can't have a
better way to do that I will play I will
play crucible all day long if I just
want to be like man I got like 30
minutes before I go to work I just wanna
just explode some people that's that's
why people play shooters you know some
want to be competitive and sweaty you
want to play your different modes but
sometimes I just want to blow some stuff
up if it's uh if it's other Guardians
great like you preaching to the choir
right now I mean I had so much fun I
dusted off my skull of dire arm and Cara
for my water and I had so much fun even
though the Nova bombs I'm not agreeing
with the Nova bomb clear yeah they were
broken but that's that aside yeah that
was broken but it was just it was just
so much fun just like I felt so close to
d1 crucible and I'm like you even when I
was dying I was laughing and I was like
to the point real like I see this that
like rock paper scissors you got a feel
for what beat what or why like if I
smack somebody but it's like you got to
play her out of supers and I was like
you're always so afraid of using supers
and crucible because everybody gets them
at the same time and no mayhem should
just be back like I mean if you need a
little while to fix the nova bomb bug
fine have one person figure that out
when that's fixed I know it's not how it
works again
fix the Nova bomb bug and then just like
leave it there or do a featured
playlists feel like I just want to blake
controls your CP playlist Mayhem's
repeat your playlist like rotate it
through bring some of that stuff back
exactly I remember we used to have that
we used to have that when you loaded up
destiny one it's part of my weekly
update that's what videos can be really
short now if there's nothing going on by
the way I've missed ya
all right well I know this has been
going forward just a wee bit of a while
a good hour yeah yeah how this one goes
but this is kind of what we wanted to do
it's like just talk about what's coming
and next week we'll probably have some
stuff to talk about it sounds like get
the deep dive inside that all these
adjustments on that on the 30th so I
mean crimsoned days is that just gonna
feel like I know is that just gonna be
like a pink version of crucible red or
green I mean is that know I was like I
don't I don't see what they're gonna
bring to it now it's like there's like a
2v2 yes yeah TP to shout to SWAT now it
does my arm huckleberry do that thing
man like that III actually enjoyed it it
was an interest I like the buff mechanic
yeah you know the person will get
enraged if they go down or whatever so I
don't mind you know I'm curious to see
what spin they put on it you know I'm
listen it's something different if you
get the buff here in mayhem mode go oh
he's got a plan to drop them both
together otherwise you're screwed
exactly they'll give me stud we'll see
I'm gonna give it a chance based on yeah
you know it was missing last last time
around so was it big time so all right
well to everybody out there um cog Nino
if you want to get a little wrap-up here
first
first flashpoint in the books like I
said a little casual fireside chat kind
of thing with Manny bonta's you know
might be a better better description of
it cuz I'm not sure flashpoint I just
need to get like a video of about an
hour of you and me somewhere sitting in
front of like the little fire pit in the
dorm have us chillin we come with
appropriate before do what this really
is but we wanted to do it you know
appreciate you know the guys that jumped
in to check out the cash out the home 0
and everybody that came through just a
you know here's some geeks that are
passionate about destiny lament and also
you know get a little excited show some
home also
what what may be coming down a fusion we
all love this game you want to see it
come back and from the ILP side um also
I'll be using flashpoint or whatever I
decided to call it stuff so um please
feel free to check us out there at the
iron Lords podcast on YouTube and also
we are the Lords going to live every
Sunday at 1 p.m. Eastern and that's the
roundtable that's Church the Lord's Day
and that's on the inner circle network
and that's at the inner circle network
YouTube 1:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
speaking of Sundays are you excited at
all about the Superbowl is that kind of
like May we still got another week I
believe not this week but um next yeah
next Sunday it's kind of a to me is
almost like a foregone conclusion let's
see what happens more so about like
seeing my friends drinks games like
honestly more people I feel like lately
as the Patriots have been there so much
it's like let's just see what happens
with the commercials of happy yeah you
go in the commercials absolutely you
know so you bought this yeah thank you
guys for if you stuck with us this long
I know we rambled off but I'm sure this
is some of the stuff many of you guys
were thinking so if you are sound off in
the comments of course check out the
iron Lords podcast in the inner circle
over there I'll get links from him put
those in the description below as you
guys know for me you'll find me on
twitch as soon as I finally moved my
computer which I built but haven't moved
it into the room so I gotta get the
streaming setup over but twitch.tv
slushee
it's a bonus everywhere that's the nice
thing too which Twitter YouTube right
here you guys can find me and but
anything you guys want to see as you
guys read these updates leave those in
the comment below for questions thoughts
stuff you guys want to see us talk about
do you got any topics you want us to
cover that are not on the update but
just for the weekly topic definitely up
for suggestions from there as well so we
are open in all ears and as always to
the Lord at the other end of the table
of which the dignity has been no well if
you guys ever listened to the iron Lord
podcast the way this gentleman
introduces
Yuni guest who steps on his show is you
know without question that uh there's a
formality and a level of gratitude that
I can't extend him so I appreciate that
and yeah everything he says about me is
totally false been like two and a half
years since uh is it two and a half
years it's about two and half years bro
since destiny Kanye's since we met so
since then all the way out here and good
old uh recording things so for all of
you guys that are out there this is my
little sign off I've been doing I have
no idea if people find a corny or not
but good afternoon good morning or good
evening but wherever you guys are at
around the world thank you and I'll see
you soon all right please